warning the following video contains
spoilers is a freaking reaction video
what do you expect oh shut up Navi so
our heroes make it to the top of the
tree and what
there's no floating city the developers
lied about the grand quest those evil
bastards ah the reunion of the sweetest
mum dad and daughter ever
how old are they again how the [ __ ] can
I take this seriously
well now that together there's nothing
that could possibly go wrong well you
didn't see this one coming
uh Admiral Ackbar do you want to take
this one it's a and here comes the main
villain as usual licking about as
threatening as a fashionable butterfly
and now I shall proceed to tell my evil
plan to the main character because that
has always worked out well what's this
you're having a party
hell yeah [ __ ] is that kind of party Oh
brilliant more rape just what my boner
ordered wait wait you're telling me
there's a pain system in the game that
could possibly affect your real-world
body how the [ __ ] did this game make it
to mass market yes boner up Oh
boner down music not sure if he's
kissing her or trying to lick her face
off oh hi season 1 villain the [ __ ] are
you doing here get up neo you are the
one you can do it as long as you believe
in the heart of the cards
remember the bonds of friendship the
power of love will find a way
okay I'm out cliche lies now what the
[ __ ] is going on no this makes any
logical sense Hey
sword art online how's your anus feeling
cuz that was a pretty big [ __ ]
massive sword tiny sword insert dick
joke here yes that's right glorify the
man who trapped thousands of people in a
game causing hundreds to die I can't
remember why he was a bad guy either let
me hear that one more time okay well one
more time yes yes this is the most epic
duel of all time beats the [ __ ] out of
the season one finale well there goes
his right hand we all know what he won't
be
now haha wanking and so comes the end to
the best villain of all time let us take
a second to remember all the great
moments he's given us blah blah romance
oh [ __ ] so are you ever gonna tell us
why you wanted to trap thousands of
people in a game no well thanks anyway
old buddy old pal hey look its plot wait
aren't we forgetting something since I'm
such a responsible father I'm gonna [ __ ]
off now to the real world and leave you
here by yourself
oh ho so what were you just doing to my
body just now oh so you're happy you can
see asana now it's not like you are just
crying about it literally two episodes
ago or anything
I can't wait to review this
[Music]